hello everyone uh this is jack
i'm glad to spend some time uh with you
to share the lessons that i've learned
on protests
i also want to share some experience
that we
that can partner have on protects
so i want to divide today's uh talk into
five
uh parts so i'll give you an overview
of target protein degradation followed
by
description of the dozen also small
molecule ligands for e3
ubiquitin ligases
because nuclear hormone receptors are
the class that have been studied the
longest
so i'll talk about that followed by um
protects for kinases so whatever have
not been covered
in the first four sections i'll make it
up in the last
section
protac is a molecule with three parts
you have a linker
that links target protein and e3
light as ligand so this molecule
serves as a molecular glue that
pulls target protein and e3 ligase
together
into truck proximity
so what once proximity is achieved
e3 like us would transfer
ubiquitous molecules onto target
proteins
once ubiquitous molecule number
is big enough the target protein
would become appended targets
so to speak so protozoan can recognize
it
coming and degrade the target protein
into amino acids
online there's a beautiful cartoon
depicting the whole process the movement
how a whole process works so i encourage
you to take a look
of that cartoon when you have a chance
projects are really really hot
if you look at the number of
publications
the number of papers in 2019
were exponentially more than previous
years
but if you had a chance to do the same
thing for the number of
papers on 2020 they would be
ex exponentially more than 2019 even
many small buy techs have been funded to
take advantage of the target protein
degradation
technology and all big farmers have some
uh you know efforts working on protests
just like any innovative ideas we all
have this hype and over promise
stage that's where we are with targeted
protein degradation
depending on the clinical outcome
of evidence two protests
one on er one or ar so we'll see how
this
uh trend goes
ian churchill actually summarized the
fiscal requirement
for fixed events to happen in order to
oxidate
target protein degradation the protein
must access intramolecular compartments
both target protein and e3 this
therefore to form ternary complex to
enable
ubiquitin transfer
in order for the transfer to happen the
ternary complex must have appropriate
conformation
so the two proteins are in vicinity of
each other so generally
this complex is u-shaped so the two
proteins meet each other
closer just like any uh equilibrium
the induced ubiquitination
rate must be faster than removal
of ubiquitin otherwise you're never
going to have enough number of
duplicating on your
target protein
and also the target protein must be
recognized by production once you have
enough number of ubiquitin
finally again like equivalent
equilibrium induced degradation rate
must be greater than the rate of the
novel
synthesis
here a few cartons are very enlightening
about the mode of action of protests so
once the protect binds to both
e3 ligase and the target protein
actually the ternary complex undergoes
dramatic confirmation change so that
the complex look like u shape
almost like circle you know it's not
totally close circle
that e3 like this and your target
protein are very
close in proximity
so that e3 like this can transfer
ubiquinone molecules onto your target
protein
so this is why this process often is
called
proximity induced degradation
before uh protests uh lincoln-induced
target protein degradation
was known for instance selective
estrogen receptor degradator this
molecule uh
by uh estradica full restaurant
was approved by the fda in
2002 that's almost 20 years ago
even though this molecule was originally
designed as a quote-unquote pure
full antagonist it was later
discovered that this molecule also
induced
a production-mediated degradation of er
alpha so it's sort of a
targeted protein degradation but this
molecule has
incomplete receptor occupancy
because of the uh you know steroid and
this lipo
sidechain it has understandably
poor solubility and bioavailability
it can only be given as an
intramolecular
intramuscular injection
more selective er degradators have been
discovered
using very small greasy degrees
so here are two examples the molecule on
the right
effectively inhibits mcf7
cell proliferation it has a good
er alpha degradation efficacy
many companies have jumped the
bandwagon of third
gilead bought this brilliant strength
from a small company
in san diego which is this company uh
this drug is in phase two
of s3 right now esther zenika's uh
third just recently
successfully completed phase one
clinical trial
i can't help to share a little trick i
learned
during the study of third
simply transforming phenol into purity
there was a 11-fold decrease of
protein binding so a little trick can
have
big impact in drug design
so that was er but for selective
ar degradators there have been some
effort as well so these two swords
were discovered by a university of
tennessee
both of them exerted broad scope ar
antagonism because they're small
molecules
pretty small they have good adamant
properties
so both of the swords induced about
eighty percent
tumor growth inhibition of linographs
from enzolutimide resistant
with ap cellulite
mammalians like human body we have
about 600 ligases because they are so
important to our
homeostasis of proteins because proteins
are
made degraded you know at all time
uh however uh so far we only have
technology about 10 little bit over 10
like this so we only have small molecule
ligands
for probably a dozen uh e3 ubiquitin
ligases so there's a lot more we can do
uh so here are the more popular one um
e3 ligands methylene
is a small molecule uh ligand for mdm2
uh methylbestatin is a ligand for
ciat1
and this vhl ligand is
surprise vhl ligand
jay brainer at harvard but now he's the
president for navratris now but when he
was at
at harvard he pioneered these
immuno modulatory drugs
as small q ligand for e3 ligas
cerebrum for instance
line-alignment bond cerebrum can produce
only degrade two
specific b-cell transcription factors
ikzf one and three
belgian has done a lot of work on
imids they could serve as
cerebral ligands as well for instance
cell gene used cc to 20
to improve ikeros and ios degradation
linking jk1 i'm going to get to that
later
and td106 at the bottom right induced
bet protein degradation
a group in japan led by nato
discovered a similar protect but they
called it specific and non-genetic iap
dependent protein eraser
but i would just call it protect
why have so many names when you are
doing exactly the same
thing however this protect
degree degraded cia p1
and xiap these two are very very similar
they're cousins
nato found that longer linker than
what is shown also led uh
degradation and changing the current
center
on this jk1 prevented
degradation so this means the uh
binding to the target protein is very
important
needless to say
fiona was a postdoc for uh
craig cruz at yale but uh
during his independent academic uh
career
he was the first one to discover
the uh van hippo
lindo ligand
so this particular small ligand
has a in vitro affinity of nanomolar
it was the best in class ligand for the
lhs2 region
as shown on your right
he also found that the typical groove
boosted potency
although the flooring gives you the
weaker affinity
we need two exactly the same
e3 uh ligands what you got you get
hormone protects for instance cm11
links two vhl ligands
it led to potent complete
and prolonged degradation of vhl in
different cell lines
the bottom one cc15 a
was highly potent and efficient
cerebral degrader so basically
the protect killed itself so you would
call it uh
uh suicide right but since there are
homo protects
i would call them homocide
but if you link two different e3 uh
ligands
together then the outcome is
unpredictable
you can only be find it out from
experiments
so for this heterodimerizing protect
it induced potent and rapid and profound
preferential degradation of thyroid
blood
over vhl in cancer cell lines
although at lower concentration weaker
degradation of dhl
was observed a little bit
there are also halo protects so
basically you
attach halogen onto e3 ligand
they are of course more drug like
because they're smaller
for this particular molecule it has
a binding affinity to vhl proteins
of 540 nanomolar
it could degrade halotec 7 fusion
protein
as you can see this could serve as
useful genetic tool
to chemically knock down proteins
monoclonal antibody and protein
conjugates
are very popular now you can see it's a
double whammy
to attack one particular target protein
pollen batuzi at stanford
discovered this light sumo targeting
camaros
she even founded company called lysia
to take advantage of her discovery
it's remarkable that the concept of
protect was
founded only 20 years ago in
2001 cruz and deichez
published the paper on the first protac
the e3 lycast ligand
was a 10 amino acid peptide
it had low potency poor cellular
permeability
and of course it was metabolically
unstable
so as far as the drug is concerned that
was not a very good drug
however the concept literally
revolutionized drug design so i wonder
if there's a nobel prize in it
at some point
the initial efforts in cruz group
were focused on nuclear homo receptors
at first
they discovered the first non-peptic e3
ligand
of course natalie is more drug-like in
comparison to
the previous peptide ligand
so this
[Music]
protect
partially degraded ar at 10 micromolar
so it's still too weak
for this ar the
the used mdm2 another
natalie as a e3 ligand
xiaoming 1 professor 1 at yofm
university of michigan
has done a lot of work in the field
of targeted protein degradation
he linked the air antagonist and the
vhl ligand with soluble and rigid linker
so this molecule is a hundred
fold more potent than the ar antagonist
on the left it reduced ar protein level
by greater than 95 percent it's
suppressed ar regulated gene
expression a single dose
effectively reduced air level in
xenograft tumor tissue
in mice
everyone wonders you know what avenues
are protect
uh clinical
compound look like to the best of our
educated gas
so this is uh
the inferred structure where um
the enzylutanate mite
and vhl ligands were linked with a very
short
ether linker
so that was air protects for er
there are a lot of work done as well so
cruz
this molecule really uh
mediated catalytic ubikini nation
it is highly specific for their target
although
the er receptor and technique itself was
not
this theme you will be seeing over and
over again
is that the prototypes can boost the
selectivity
exponentially so this molecule protect
was efficient
in vivo knockdown in mice
professor one's er protect
has a dc50 of 0.17
in the mcf7 uh
sales dmax is awesome almost 100
but tmx is a little bit uh short
it is more effective than full best
trains in sales
so this is almost a given because uh
serve is so small
if you go through all the trouble making
a protect it has to be
more effective otherwise what's the
point right
again you know everybody wonders what
arv 471 looks like and nobody knows
but to the best of my guess it would be
something look like the bottom right so
we'll have to
wait and see when avenues discloses
those structures at some point
this is not a cancer target but it's
still remarkable to me
because a group in china
discovered a orally active protect for
hmg co-a receptor
the linked ligand
with a low-volt stating which is the
first marketed
uh statin called mavericker
by merck so
as you expected this lactone
is a pro drug in vivo it becomes acid
which is more potent i think it's
remarkable for this such a big molecule
to be uh orally active
kinase inhibitors have been
extensively studied so i think fda has
approved over 60
planets inhibitors so they are lower
hanging fruits for medicinal chemists
and drug discovery
you know in general so making protect
for them is uh
it's an easier thing to do
so it was also cruz who discovered that
uh 12 atom linker
was ideal to link this
rib k2 inhibitor with vhl
ligand it mediated catalytic
uv kitination and degrade
the kinase with the ec50 of 1.4
nanomolar
it is highly specific for their targets
which is a thousand fold for rib k2
kinase this was shown to be efficiently
in vivo knockdown in mice
clinic was the first kindness inhibitor
ever
got approved by the fda so this
was intensively studied um
cruz found out you know it's not a
guarantee
you just link a e3 ligand that you will
have
the kindness degraded so the lesson to
learn
the lesson learned is that both the
target elegant
and the recruit e3 like this
should be varied early and rapidly uh to
generate a protect with the desired
degradation um profile
otherwise you will be sparking you know
in the
park in the round tree for a while and
west near time
uh here uh a japanese group use the
methyl
that's ticking that binds to a cellular
iap ciap this
induced dcr-able protein degradation
the few dcr-able inhibitors
that i showed before were all
competitive equipment here
nato found that for allosteric
inhibitors
protect works as well so
estimate nib is the uh
allosteric kindness movement by
navaratus
it's either in s3 or probably uh
approved already
now to link that with a vhl
ligand he found out that
it has a binding affinity against evo1
ciap12 and xiap
it induced potent bcr-able
protein degradation so the lesson
taking home is that not only competitive
kindness inhibitors are good to
make protect so are those allosteric
sites
as long as they bind so binder
is good enough for protect doesn't
necessarily have to be
inhibitor antagonist or agonist
all we need is a binder
now this tank binding kindness is pretty
uh
potent has a dc50 of 12 nanomolar
and totally in normal sense but it's not
that impressive
in the uh protag field dmax
96 it is selective against a
closed uh kinase close cousin
ikk so this is a
chemical 2 to x tbk1
as a target in mutant teres cancer cells
for anaplastic lymphoma cannas
the uh protect decreased
cellular level of oncogenic active
alk fusion proteins in a concentration
and time dependent manner in two cancer
cell lines so it's not a fluke and
this is also celery bloom and the
production
dependent
for this protect for pi3k it induced
remarkable pi3k degradation
and down regulated the phosphorylation
of
those three kinases in liver cancer
cells
htt2 it also inhibits tumor cells
uh proliferation by induction of
autophagy
instead of apoptosis or cell
cycle arrest so it has a pretty novel
mechanism of action
for this flap3 protect it induced
degradation of
flt3 internal tandem duration mutant
at low nanomolar concentration it
inhibits cell growth
more potently than the world head alone
so that's a given too
it also inhibits fear of targets
of kindnesses and finally it
induced flt3 itd
degradation in vivo
was one of the first kindness that gave
rise to covalent inhibitor
the britain nip is such
a irreversible covalent inhibitor but
here
the protect removed the microacceptor
and link it with the cerebellum ligand
this molecule mt802 recruits btk to the
cerebral
e3 lubricating ligase complex then
triggers you btk ubiquitination
and degradation via uh protozoa
so namely this is a bonafide protein
like many protects it binds to fear of
target kinases
than ibrutinib it also
has greater than 99 degradation at
nanomolar concentrations very very
potent
some group led by uh timworth
wanted to use this microacceptor in
their protect
but they couldn't find any degradation
using the protec however if they use
reverse body bound target and then it
worked
a group in israel
led by london found out by
correct choice of linkers and uh
e3 uh ligase lincoln which is celebrant
here
they were able to degrade
all three types of ligands for
btk so that includes reversible
non-covalent just your garden variety
drug
irreversible covalent inhibitor
as well as this jet reversible covalent
inhibitor so they
all have a less than 10 nanomolar dc50
and greater than 85 degradation
targeted protein degradation also works
for protein protein
interactions here the ppi is
mdm2 and p53
md224 is nanomolar
potency in cell it was efficacious in
rs-411
linograph animal models
but because of its not ideal biophysical
properties
it has to be given multiple iv dosing at
25 milligrams per kilo every second day
but if you do it every day probably
would be a too toxic
i suspect
for this irreversible covalent protect
for our breath it accelerated
degradation
of breath kindness by recruiting
ups in mcf7 cell line
it affected expression of mcl1
a downstream protein of bref
okay so we have covered mostly
uh nuclear hormone receptor protects and
kindness uh protects
but there are many other uh protect
targets mostly in oncology actually
almost
exclusively in college ship too
was considered a non-druggable
target for decades because
phosphates is so polar you need a really
really polar
molecule to uh inhibit it so the only
way
to have an orally bioavailable drug is
allosteric inhibitor so that was
achieved
by navajos some
seven eight nine years ago
so their ship behavior now is in phase
two
uh clinical trials for treating cancer
xiaomi 1 took navada's ship to inhibitor
and linked it with vh l1 ligand
and he successfully achieved
a ship too degradation
so this was such a news once the paper
was published
two critique reviews were
concurrently published as well so it was
a big deal
if you ask me you know what are the two
hottest areas
in drug discovery or medicinal chemistry
i would say
oh keras g12c inhibitors and
protects so of course obviously knew
this
better than everyone else so he combined
these two hottest areas together
and created a protect for keras g12c
it was able to degrade keras g12c
at the gdp
state because keras g2c binds to
gdp as well as gtp
here i showed previous already jay
brenner's very very early
bromo domain inhibitor here
i just want to mention that the jq1
is uh named after the chemist who made
this molecule
jq stands for dream chi so wow he's very
famous now
this db t1 showed anti-tumor
activity although it has a per anatomy
uh property with the half-life only 40
minutes so this is why
it required daily ip injection
so not very good
here uh sioni was the one who first
used the vhl e3 ligands
in the field so this is the first
prototype with the vhl ligand this
is reversible and long lasting
and achieved unexpectedly selective
removal
of brd4 over brd2
and brd3 so this remarkable
increase of selectivity is widespread
for our products
avenues has a very advanced molecule
probably in
clinical trial arv 771
as well as rrv825
so arv825 recruits the brd4
to the e3 ubiquitin ligas cerebellum
namely is a bonafide protect it led to
fast
efficient and prolonged
degradation of brd4 in all
broken lymphoma cell lines so this
molecule has profound anti-leukemic
effect
very impressive
uh here
protect has showed profound
plasticity for their interactions so
different linkers
can lead to distinct targets
specific arrangements of ligase targeted
interface
as you can see here depends on the
length
of the linker 23 6 or 57
the binding complex the ternary complex
have completely different confirmation
that's quite uh remarkable
here is uh professor one's
personal bet protect
pop one has been quite a
hot area in uh oncology for this
uh
protect the linking nothing it induced
significant part 1 cleavage and
led to program cell death in
mdmb 231 cell line
protects are not a panacea it doesn't
always work
so choosing the correct linker and
right uh e3 like ligand
is critical in it's still uh you know
trial and
error stage for us for instance you know
my friend
holly stillwater at urban made this
uh dhodh protect
but he wasn't able to find any uh
of this enzyme degradation
wingpur crews and churchill summarized
advantages of protects for us they have
the ability to target the
undruggable proteins proteomes
many many proteins that were not
draggable we can
use it to use protect to attack it
the overcome accumulation of drug target
because we just degraded
drug target alteration because the
protects could cause mutations and
binding partners
we already saw over and over again we
could have
gained of specific specificity
like uh brd4 versus two and three
high cellular potency driven by
catalytic mode of action because once
the protect molecule has finished its
job
the protect molecule is free again to do
another
damage so to speak
it is uh even driven pharmacodynamics
and has prolonged pharmacodynamic effect
there are many challenges of protects
the greatest tenant
is the biophysical properties when you
link
two things together plus linker the
smallest molecule would be
you know greater than 700
so we need optimize extensively
to achieve compromise of oral exposure
solubility and clearance
furthermore targeted protein degradation
has
very complex functional mechanism
you need to pull two proteins together
so the ternary complex formation is
pretty complex and then
you have to uh undergo ubiquitin
transfer
that require delicate confirmation of
the ternary complex
and shuttling to the protozoa
we have we at campon have worked
extensively on this field
during the last decade we have worked
pretty much all type of protects
using different linkers different legacy
ligands
so the ligands that i showed below
before we have worked on all of them
and we prepared most of the reference
compounds shown
previously almost every group
in temp chemistry
very well versed with the synthesis
of protects in addition our biology
department
has developed a suite of this ubiquitin
protestant synthesis platform including
e1e2e3 activity
for the inhibitor and also the e3
activity essay for protects
as well as ternary complex formation
so we have a lot of assets
in this field and here i'm just showing
a example
all right it's great uh to have a
spend some time with you or review
protests
you are welcome to contact me at
jack.lee
at campartner.us and keep in touch